de cette ville au sud de l'iscid chance
qu il ne reste que des bâtiments en
ruines les combats pour contrôler cette
agglomération clés du donbass se sont
poursuivies ce lundi selon les autorités
locales l'armée russe contrôle désormais
la plupart des quartiers résidentiels de
severodonezk mais plus du tiers serait
toujours aux mains des forces du
chrétienne qui tentent également de
protéger licite chante qu hier dimanche
je pense que nous pouvons déjà dire avec
certitude que l'armée russe a accumulé
un nombre suffisant d'armes pour lancer
une offensive de grande envergure
ils ont accumulé une énorme quantité de
technologie
une avancée russes redoutent aussi les
habitants de cramât torse située à une
cinquantaine de kilomètres au sud-est de
severodonezk malgré l'inquiétude au
moins soixante mille habitants ont
décidé de rester une fois que les routes
c'est beaucoup malheureusement
mais vous savez avec la guerre qui se
rapprochent c'est plus dangereux donc
vous devez prendre soin de vos proches
aider les gens
leur distribuer l'aide alimentaire
autre région théâtre d'intenses
bombardements ce lundi la ville de
donetsk la capitale de la république
séparatiste pro russe des attaques
menées depuis quelques jours par l'armée
ukrainienne
nous voulons partir d'ici juste pour
fuir cette horreur cela ne s'est jamais
produit auparavant on ne comprend pas ce
qui se passe ici les rues sont également
accusé les ukrainiens d'avoir bombardé
trois plateformes de forage au large de
la crimée selon moscou sept personnes
seraient portées disparues